libre pero bajo una nube de polémica el
vicepresidente de samsung lee jae-yong
fue excarcelado después de haber
completado año y medio detrás de las
rejas por entregar sobornos entre otros
delitos de corrupción relacionados con
el escándalo que terminó en la salida
del anterior gobierno de corea del sur
he causado muchos problemas entre la
gente lo lamento profundamente me dio
tanta
estoy escuchando los problemas las
críticas las preocupaciones y las altas
expectativas por mí voy a trabajar duro
uno de los hombres más ricos del mundo
con 53 años fue encarcelado en un primer
momento en 2017 antes de ser liberado
por una apelación la corte suprema del
país ordenó entonces repetir el juicio
que terminó en su regreso a prisión en
enero de este año había sido declarado
culpable de sobornar a la mano derecha
de la expresidenta párking quien también
terminó en la cárcel después de
crecientes llamados de las grandes
empresas para restituir el liderazgo de
samsung en medio de la pandemia el
ministerio de justicia anunció este
lunes su indulto que supone una
reducción de dos años y medio sobre su
condena esta liberación va en línea con
la larga tradición en corea del sur de
indultar a líderes empresariales
encarcelados por corrupción y evasión
fiscal y otros temas financieros aunque
el nieto del fundador de samsung
permanece en un proceso en torno a
manipulación de acciones ahora su camino
se abre para volver a tomar el control
de la empresa familiar más grande de la
nación